YO, LEMME GET IN THAT DOGHOUSE.
- NO, SORRY, IT'S TAKEN.
- COME ON.
- NO, I DON'T WANT--
I'M IN THIS DOGHOUSE RIGHT NOW.
PLEASE LEAVE.
- I'M C-CZAR.
- MY NAME IS--I'M DENISE.
I'M JUST--I'M DENISE.
- CAN I TELL YOU A SECRET?
- SURE.
- I WAS CRATE TRAINED.
- WELL, THAT'S COOL.
- YO, THAT'S A COOL
KATNISS COSTUME.
- YEAH, I'M KATNISS
FROM THE MOVIE KAT--
- YEAH, FROM HUNGER GAMES.
- THAT'S WHAT I MEANT.
I MISS MY REAL CLOTHES,
THOUGH.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT I'M NOT
NORMALLY DRESSED LIKE KATNISS.
- THEN WHY DON'T YOU GO HOME?
- I DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW TO GET
HERE, I'M NOT EVEN FROM HERE.
I FLEW ON AN AIRPLANE TO COME
MEET MY AUNT ELIZABETH.
BUT SHE DIDN'T EVEN COME
MEET ME AT THE AIRPORT.
NOW I'M LIVING IN A DOGHOUSE.
- RIGHT? IT'S LIKE
YOU CAN'T TRUST ADULTS.
- YOU CAN'T CRUSH THE DOLT?
- YOU CAN'T TRUST ADULTS.
- OH, YOU--
WELL, YEAH, YOU CAN.
YOU JUST HAVE TO
TRUST THE RIGHT ONES.
- ARE YOU SCARED?
- I NEED, LIKE,
A PARENT OR A GUARDIAN
TO GET ME OUT OF HERE.
- I WANNA BE WILD AND
RUN AWAY FROM RESPONSIBILITY,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME I'M LIKE,
"THIS GIRL NEEDS MY HELP."
- I THINK YOU KNOW WHAT TO DO.
- DENISE, THIS IS MY FRIEND
RON FUNCHES.
- ARE YOU FROM THE ORIGINAL
MOTION PICTURE DICK TRACY
STARRING WARREN BEATTY AND HIS
GIRLFRIEND AT THE TIME MADONNA?
- YOU'RE GOOD AT MOVIES.
- THANK YOU.
- RON FUNCHES, WHAT SHOULD I DO?
THIS POOR GIRL NEEDS HELP.
- ANSWER'S ON YOUR ARM, MAN.
WHY DO YOU THINK
WE TATTOOED YOU?
- "MAKING GOOD CHOICES,
SETTING LIMITS."
I'M GONNA GET YOU
OUTTA HERE, DENISE.
YOU TRUST ME?
- YES, C-CZAR.
- ALL RIGHT, DENISE.
- OKAY.
- I CAN FEEL MY PARENTAL
INSTINCTS KICKING IN.
[triumphant synthesizer music]
AND I SEE
A LITTLE GIRL IN NEED
AND I WANNA STRAIGHT-UP
HELP YOU.
BECAUSE I'M A VILLAIN.
BUT I'M A GOOD VILLAIN.